what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another talking Thrones Q&A
video a recently posted a comment on my
YouTube community tab and I asked
everyone to leave any questions they may
have down below the last time I checked
there was over 130 questions and I'll
obviously can't answer them all or else
this video would be well over an hour
long but I will answer some of the
questions that had the most likes I'm
assuming the questions what the most
likes are the ones that you want to hear
my answer for the most so let's get
started with those right away the first
question is from something something
something jellyfish sassy could Sansa be
Jon's niece Anissa in the book she has
dreams or nightmares of her death she
dreams of ice stabbing her in the chest
and her eyes turned white also Jon
dreams that he kills a redhead a girl
with thick long red hair similar to hers
could this mean that he has to kill
Santa his most beloved sister and the
one he swore to protect in season six
could Jon kill her in order to protect
her from turning into a white I know it
seems crazy but not impossible thank you
for your question but first I do have to
say Sansa is not Jon's most beloved
sister Arya is actually Jon's most
beloved sister in the books Jon and Arya
think about each other more than any of
the other siblings but John does have
love for Sansa I won't deny that your
question is interesting though because
you do raise some good points but in my
opinion Sansa will not be nice Anissa I
think if anyone is going to be nice and
Nisa it will be either Daenerys or
Melisandre you may not have noticed but
I did make a video about each one of
these characters being nice Anissa and
to me it would make a lot more sense if
Melisandre was actually nice Anissa
Melisandre has been the character who
preaches about this prophecy the most
Melisandre has made many sacrifices by
burning people alive but I think it
would be interesting if Melisandre had
to give the ultimate sacrifice by
sacrificing herself in order for light
burner to be forged Melisandre is very
powerful and magical and she kind of
already has a fire burning inside of her
when we saw Melisandre at her full
strength she didn't even need to wear a
coat while she was at the wall because
her body was so warm
and I bet if you plunged a sword into
her heart it would catch fire and create
Lightbringer I don't want to turn this
entire video into a nice Aneesa theory
but let me read one quote to you from
the books and then I will move on to the
next question
this quote seems to be foreshadowing
Melisandre being nice Aneesa in one of
Davis's chapters in the third book a
Storm of Swords he says something very
interesting that relates to this
question after Davos nearly died during
the Battle of Blackwater Bay someone
saves him from that small Rock Island he
washed up on and as he is being taken
back to Dragonstone he starts thinking
about the battle and how Melisandre is
starting to take over Stannis his life
in Davos thinks to himself and says she
has broke him like a man breaks a horse
she would ride him to power if she could
and for that she gave my sons to the
fire I will cut the living heart from
her breast and see how it burns in my
opinion that relates perfectly to the
Ozora high in Nissa Nissa prophecy
almost word-for-word the Zora High
prophecy states this time he called for
his wife
Nissa Nissa and asked her to bear her
breast he drove his sword into her
living heart her soul combining with the
steel of the sword creating Lightbringer
the red sword of Heroes Davos used those
same words when he thought about
stabbing Melisandre he said the words
living heart and breast and he thought
about it burning just like the sword
would burn if it was plunged through her
breast into her living heart I believe
if anyone is gonna be nice and Nisa it
will be Melisandre she's coming back to
Westeros to die and she believes death
by fire is the purest death so it would
make sense to me if Melisandre
sacrificed herself instead of someone
else this time the next question is from
s Davis I really would love to hear what
you think if there were 7 characters who
reminded you of the 7 from one God of
the Seven faces the mother the father
the warrior the Crone the Smith the
stranger in the maiden who would be who
thank you for the question as Davis and
I'm gonna be honest with you though I
haven't ever really put much thought
into this idea before if I had to pick
seven characters that are still alive
who best
fit those descriptions I would pick Arya
Stark for the stranger the stranger does
represent death in the unknown and I do
think that fits Arya pretty well ginjury
would be my Smith who represents
craftsmanship I would pick Jaime
Lannister or even Jon Snow for the
warrior they have both displayed courage
in battle even the Hound would fit that
description although he did abandon the
Battle of Blackwater Bay
I think old man fits the description of
the Crone the best even though she is
dead old man definitely had wisdom and
foresight Sean's a stark would be a good
fit for the maiden she is beautiful and
fairly innocent compared to most of the
other characters I'm not too sure about
the mother though I guess my Sande might
be a good pic for that or maybe even
Daenerys although she isn't very fertile
herself or is she and for the father I
would have to say Jon Snow
I think Brienne could also fit that
description in a sense I never really
put that much thought into this before
which characters would all of you pick
for the Seven leave your opinions down
in the comments but let's move on to the
next question the next question is from
Samantha Christensen and she asks can
you see a possibility that both John and
Danny survive Andrew as equals could the
bittersweet calm elsewhere sure the
bittersweet ending could play out a
thousand different ways in my opinion I
have considered so many different
scenarios when trying to predict how
this would end but the question is while
John and Daenerys both survive and rule
together as equals that almost sounds
like too perfect of an ending I have
always felt like one of them would die
and I have been leaning more towards
than Aerys dying
I don't want Daenerys to die but I feel
like she will Daenerys has had one
mission during this entire series and
that is to become the queen of the Seven
Kingdoms something she believes she was
born to do she still thinks she has the
strongest claim but as we all know Jon
Snow has the better claim and John
doesn't give two shits about whether he
is in power or not he just wants to save
the realm and do what's right so I think
it would be kind of ironic if Daenerys
died before she ever achieved the one
thing she has won in this entire time
but instead John ends up out living
everyone and he is left with all the
power all the
he has never wanted it that's just how I
feel right now but I'm not opposed to
changing my opinion the next question is
from Christian back in season 3 aria
tells the hound that she will put a
knife through his eye and out the back
of his skull do you think that this was
foreshadowing he has turned into a white
and/or he has to kill him I know Game of
Thrones is big on foreshadowing that is
a really good question Christian I
absolutely remember that scene and this
is one that I have thought about from
time to time I used to think it might
mean something but I'm not so sure
anymore I don't see Arya ever killing
the Hound but I do like the nice spin
you put on this question because if the
Hound is turned into a white Arya could
still do this and it wouldn't
necessarily ruin how we think of their
relationship aurilla wouldn't be killing
him out of hate if it happened like this
and I actually think the Hound will
survive the entire series though the
Hound is part of my cripples bastards
and broken things prediction I believe
all of those characters who were
featured in that episode will be the
main characters who participate in the
Great War and survive the series so I
have to say no I do not think this will
happen but it is an interesting idea
nonetheless so thanks for the question
the next one is from gaming with a white
guy he says do you think Jon Snow's
parents will be different in the books
absolutely not Jon Snow's parents will
be exactly the same in the books Jon
Snow's parents are Rhaegar Targaryen and
Lyanna stark there are no if ands or
buts about this in my opinion I am 100%
confident about this and let's just say
I am working on something that I will
show you all soon I know there are tons
of our plus L equals J videos out there
already but what I'm working on is a
little bit more definitive than anything
you've ever seen
I am currently rereading the books and
I'm halfway through a Storm of Swords
once I finish them I will break all of
this down in an epic fashion and that's
all I can say right now I hate to give
you the short answer but I don't want to
reveal too much in this video next
question is from Dirac Blackfyre do you
think the night king knew that Daenerys
was coming with her dragons I just
thought that it was kind of odd that
they just happened to have chains big
enough to pull a dead dragon out of the
lake with them
this is another very good question this
is something I mentioned during my
season 7 breakdown video immediately
after this episode aired because I also
felt like this was a setup by the night
King the giant change didn't bother me
that much because there was a dog right
next to that lake and if you look
closely you can see the chains wrapped
around the dog as they were pulling the
dragon out but there were some other
things that made me suspicious this was
the first time we ever saw the night
king and the white Walker show up with
ice javelins it's kind of weird that
they mysteriously had brand new weapons
when the night king is always known to
carry a curved ice sword then the night
king just allows them to sit on that
rock for days when he clearly could have
killed them by throwing the ice spears
like he did with the dragon also before
John even went on this mission bran sent
the Ravens north of the wall to spy on
the night king and when brain sees the
nigh can he is sitting on the same rock
that John and company end up getting
surrounded on I think he may have been
waiting right there for them to show up
so he could spring his trap on them it
did seem like he was purposely waiting
for something
we know the night king is very powerful
even more powerful than brain is right
now so it's not out of the realm of
possibility that he knew that dragons
would show up he can clearly tap into
the weirwood net and see thinks too so I
won't rule this idea out the next
question is from a mando do you believe
John will betray Daenerys considering
her prophecy that she will be betrayed
three times the last one out of love it
might also add to the Ozora hide legend
where azor Ahai killed his wife to
create light bringer thank you for the
question a mando this is one of the many
reasons why I believe if there will be a
literal Nissa Nissa then has to be
Daenerys or Melisandre the only problem
is I don't see John outright betraying
Daenerys not unless he has a very good
reason to do so
but maybe something will happen that
will cause Daenerys to think John has
betrayed her in some way
although we would know John didn't
actually betray her just as an example
John might decide to end his intimate
relationship with Daenerys once he finds
out they are related but Daenerys could
see this as a betrayal especially if
she's in love with John and
wants to be with John no matter the
circumstances I'm not really sure what
else would cause John to turn his back
on Daenerys now though there isn't much
time left and he desperately needs
Danny's help in this war Daenerys would
actually have to start purposely burning
innocent people for John to want to kill
her now but that's just my opinion if
you have any other ideas feel free to
leave a comment the next question is
from Harry and he says do you think
Danny's dragons will easily beat Vasari
on the Dragons grow enormous Lee each
season where as an undead dragon may not
when you put it like that you would
think two dragons should easily beat one
dragon but I don't think it will be that
simple
if you would like to hear a more
detailed answer about this question you
should definitely watch the video I made
about how to beat the Night Kings dragon
the turkey thing about answering this
question is we don't know all of the
rules yet we know whites can be killed
by fire and dragon glass and White
Walkers can be killed by dragon glass
and Valyrian steel but all of those
weapons are made up of either fire or
magic from dragons fire so you have to
ask yourself can an undead dragon be
killed by weapons that are made up of
magical properties from another dragon
no one knows that answer yet all we can
do is guess I would like to think if you
put a Valyrian steel bolt or arrow
through vissarion's eye it should die
but I'm not sure if dragon fire will be
enough even though Vissarion it's
technically dead or Undead Danny's
dragons might not be able to kill this
Ariane with their fire so that means
they will need to make some kind of
projectile out of dragon glass or
Valyrian steel or they could use arrows
made out of the weirwood tree in the
godswood that should do the trick to
Daenerys may have two dragons but I
wouldn't expect her to take down the
knight king's dragon as easy as it may
seem I think they will make the battle
as dramatic as possible even if they
have to throw logic out the window which
we know they have no problem doing I
think this is a good place to end
today's video though I want to thank
everyone that posted questions and
everyone for watching the video I really
appreciate your support especially to
those of you that support the channel on
patreon I hope to see you all come back
tomorrow for the next one have a great
day I'll see you down in the comment
section
by
[Music]
[Music]